voilà c'est très très très clair on va
voir sur le tableau mesdames et
messieurs vous allez voir l'ampleur des
gains et l'ampleur des pertes de l'autre
côté
regardez les gains pour les libérons
atlantique +3 terre-neuve +9 au nouveau
brunswick plus 7 en nouvelle écosse est
plus un à l'île du prince édouard et
c'est l'histoire
opposé pour les conservateurs - 1 - 18.4
moyens en fait c'est pas compliqué les
conservateurs n'ont jamais fait un aussi
mauvais score en atlantique depuis la
confédération
je vous dirai à terre-neuve depuis 49
bien sûr et pour le npd s'est pas
tellement plus joyeux - 2 - 1 - 3
donc d'où on voulait partir pour
peut-être faire des gains même si du
côté du npd on voulait pas faire mais le
gain mais d'où on voulait partir mais
tout cela semble s'effondrer et en
suffrages bien là c'est très clair les
libéraux passe de 29
la dernière fois à 64 c'est 35 points de
pourcentage de plus loin et 21 points
c'est beaucoup là dans une élection - 21
sous chute à brut et 13 de moins pour le
npd à messieurs dames le portrait on
fera pas de nuance est assez clair